[Laughter]
well hello there boyles and ghouls we
hope we didn't startle you too hard
there it's only us your good old friends
at scp explained we all love a little
fright now and then don't we after all
that would explain our fascination with
the morbid tales of the scp foundation
rotten old men who can walk through
walls and tear you limb from limb in
their own private house nightmarish
circuit diseases that turn anyone who
touches them into a horrible abomination
evil masks that kill you and take over
your body using it to do acts of great
cruelty until you melt down into black
goo oh
you're not scared of those you think
you're so tough so prepared for anything
that even those anomalous beings of pure
terror can't break through the
impenetrable shell of your bravery well
i suppose we better bring out the big
guns then just remember when you're
huddled in the corner bones rattling in
fear that you brought this on yourself
after all
there's no entity quite as good as
inspiring screams as scp
2006
so please stay awhile and find out why
this one's called too spooky
we're sorry you had to hear that but you
really can't blame us for having a
little theatricality with this one in
fact having a good grasp of
theatricality is actually essential to
everyone dealing with scp-2006
forget gunplay rituals and mind games
scp-2006 requires foundation subsidized
acting lessons in order to work on his
containment which even as foundation
containment methods go is pretty darn
strange when you got into this line of
work you probably expected you'd be in
high intensity battles with scp-682
or attending conferences on how to best
repel the menace of the scarlet king not
acting out scenes from a streetcar named
desire with dr bright but believe us
it's important work as they'll probably
tell you at these classes there are no
small parts only small actors you won't
spend time at these sessions perfecting
shakespearean soliloquies instead you'll
be adopting a much narrower focus
learning how to properly act and express
fear the more convincingly scared you
can appear the better because when it
comes to scp 2006 your job and
potentially even your life depend on it
plus it's the only time that being your
pants and collapsing on the job may
actually get you a raise rather than
just a series of strange looks from your
co-workers when you pass that course
with flying colors you'll finally be
ready to actually come face to face with
the prince of nightmares himself
scp-2006 by this point you've had it
drilled into your head so many times
that you could never forget it for the
love of god whatever this thing does you
act scared don't stonewall don't smile
and whatever you do don't laugh
laughing at scp-2006 is probably the
fastest way you can get demoted to
swabbing feces in scp-173's
chamber if you know what's good for you
you'll dial up that fear when the big
day comes you're sent into scp-2006's
airtight containment chamber with a
special package that time of the month
has come once again you need to deliver
the goods you spot a television in the
corner first still on but tuned to
static you're pondering what a waste of
electricity this is when scp-2006
who'd been hiding behind an armchair
decided to finally strike he barely had
time to realize what was going on when a
large dark shape suddenly blotted out
your vision it was over six feet tall
and looked well it looked like a man in
an exceedingly cheap gorilla costume
except with a goofy diving helmet with
what looked like tv antennas on top it
waved its arms wildly as if to hammer
home the point that yes this really was
happening and you should be terrified by
it the creature bellowed fear me mortal
i am the mighty roman cower in fear
at that moment your weeks of training
kicked in almost like a reflex you let
out an ear piercing shriek and drop down
to the floor desperately crawling away
from the goofy looking creature eyes
wide breathing heavy moments frantic and
defensive you gather yourself up in one
of the room's corners and curl into a
ball covering your face imbuing your
voice with a well practiced quiver you
say please mighty roman don't hurt me i
have so much to live for just please let
me go the monster holds a quote-unquote
menacing pose for a few seconds longer
before slackening into a joyful laugh it
even extended a rubbery gorilla paw to
help you up of course you hesitate for a
few seconds gazing fearfully waiting for
it to say it's just me doc i got you
pretty good didn't i and as far as he
knows yes he did you're sure to never
slip into the body language of comfort
it's utterly vital that scp-2006 truly
believes that he's scary to you even
though he looks like a terrible monster
costume from an even worse low-budget
b-movie though specifically the roman
the monster from the 1950 trash classic
robot monster you tell scp-2006 that
you're here with some more stimulus
material for him and hand him a plastic
bag when he asks you what you've brought
him this time you tell him you can't
even look at it if you so much as laid
eyes on it you'd slip into a terrified
state of catatonia you'd honestly rather
look at 096 than look at what you've
brought him today
scp-2006 cocked his head to the side and
asked what's 096 oh
no
the terror that was faked before wasn't
quite so fake now you'd slipped up buddy
and if you didn't come up with a good
save quickly you would be in deep
trouble you gulp and take a quick breath
trying to compose yourself before saying
that 096 is just another movie one
that's not nearly as scary as the one
you've prepared for him it seemed to
satisfy him so you internally breathe a
sigh of relief and turn to make your
exit you've just left
scp-2006 with a dvd copy of the 1977
classic deathbed the bed that eats a
somewhat obscure horror movie about an
evil bed created by a demon that should
tie the eccentric anomaly over for
another month so you're probably
wondering what actually just happened
what's the logic what are the
connections between this strange
sequence of events we all just witnessed
well it may seem bizarre now once you
know more about
scp-2006 it'll all make sense we can't
promise it'll actually seem any less
bizarre by the end though
scp-2006 is a ketter class
shape-shifting anomaly its default form
is a floating sphere of about 50
centimeters in diameter not exactly
terrifying and this is actually a big
problem for scp-2006
as the mischievous anomaly has an almost
compulsive desire to scare people not to
physically harm them in any way just
give them a good old-fashioned spook
he's shown to be pretty much
indestructible so neutralization is off
the table you may be thinking he seems
like a pretty harmless goofball why
would anyone want to neutralize him and
well we'll answer that one later back to
scp-2006 his favorite hobby scaring
people while 2006 seems to practically
live off of giving a good scare he's
thankfully no pennywise 2006 has no
inherent knowledge of what scares humans
and thus has to learn what scares humans
from external sources this unique
weakness to scp-2006's ability is one
the foundation has discovered as an
ingenious method of exploiting for its
containment they simply keep
scp-2006 misinformed on what people
actually find scary tricking it to make
sure that it's always hopelessly inept
at its hobby their method of achieving
this is twofold firstly they give
scp-2006 a monthly supply of the worst
horror movies you can imagine true
bargain bucket b-movie schlock troll 2
leprechaun in the hood birdemic shock
and terror a personal favorite the
ginger dead man the beast of yucca flats
plan 9 from outer space a runner-up for
me the creeping terror the man without a
body manos the hands of fate track of
the moon beast and of course the seminal
classic iga a movie about an evil
caveman being unfrozen and
terrorizing palm springs movies like
this are a perfect mechanism for
tricking scp-2006
because it sees the characters in the
movies reacting with fear to the
terrible hokey monsters rampaging across
backlots and sound stages and starts to
believe that these b-movie beasts are
actually scary that's the first part of
the trick and you've probably already
figured out the second half the
foundation makes sure that any employees
who interact with scp 2006 in any
capacity must play the part of appearing
actually
genuinely frightened by it this one-two
punch of trickery keeps scp-2006
successfully bamboozled as such despite
being a creature largely based around
creating fear albeit in a more friendly
playful way than most anomalies it's
seen as a joke among staff members it
wouldn't be surprising to hear that
different staff members took turns
laughing at surveillance footage or that
the latest site halloween party a few
drunken researchers tried to trick
scp-2006 into assuming the form of david
s pumpkins from saturday night live i
believe they also received angry phone
calls from tom hanks's agent the next
day as you could probably gather
developing such an unimpressed attitude
to containing anomalies with the scp
foundation is never a good thing after
all even some of the most innocent
looking ones can hide surprisingly dark
secrets dr randall owings the site
director for site 118 where scp-2006 is
held released a stern memorandum to
everyone working in 2006's proximity it
read i've been getting reports of some
of the lacks behavior regarding scp-2006
many personnel have been heard laughing
at scp-2006 during surveillance when it
watches a new movie or when it attempts
to scare individuals some personnel have
been heard questioning why scp-2006 is
classified as a ketter entity i am here
to remind you that a ketter entity is a
ketter entity regardless of how
innocuous it may seem no
scp-2006 is not a rampaging demigod nor
is it a regenerating super lizard
however it possesses the same level of
danger as any other ketter that the
foundation has contained think of
scp-2006's purpose it wishes to scare
people imagine what would happen if
scp-2006 broke containment and found out
what really scared people imagine if it
saw the horror and fear of war or the
concepts of paranoia or phobia as common
to each and every human being imagine if
it found the true horror of a nuclear
holocaust or an xk-class scenario now
couple that with an entity that
possesses shape-shifting abilities with
no known limits and you'll understand
why it's classified as keter all
personnel mentioned above have been
suitably disciplined i do not want to
hear about this again
scp-2006 is only as harmless as the
foundations containment procedures allow
it to be it's why it can never know
about other anomalies or any actually
frightening works of fiction if ever
scp-2006 became aware of the true
sources of human fear there would be no
stopping it seeing as the creature
appears to be indestructible like many
of the anomalies kept under lock and key
by the scp foundation it is a ticking
time bomb that one little mistake could
turn into an utter catastrophe terrible
movies and theatrical staff members need
to keep
scp-2006 in the dark about what actually
scares us because beyond that the only
limit to the danger of scp 2006 is the
human imagination and that my friends is
a very spooky thought indeed now go
check out scp-426
i am a toaster and the horror of body
stealing rain
scp-3300 for more of the most bizarre
anomalies out there